snow is falling down just a little bit
the world so quiet and still saddles out
there flying around got it
during e3 2013 Tom Clancy's the division
was officially announced the unveiling
showed a seven-minute gameplay clip with
the seemingly endless amount of depth
impressive gameplay and beautiful
graphics that was met with a huge amount
of hype from the gaming community the
demo introduced the devastation that hit
New York City following a viral outbreak
that originated with the handling of
money on one of retails busiest days of
the year
Black Friday Tom Clancy's the division
was inspired by real worlds Vince
operation dark winter a bioterrorist
attack simulation on the United States
and directive 51 presidential directive
which claims power to execute procedures
for continuity of federal government in
the event of catastrophic emergency also
showcase to e3 was a companion app that
would allow players to join the game
using a tablet using the app players
will be able to join a team as a drone
that could offer technical support to
players on console and PC after some
delays at e3 2015 the game's final
release date and controversial PvE VP
area the dark zone was revealed but also
confirmed was that the companion app had
been scrapped on the 18th of February
2016 the divisions open beta began for
Xbox one with Playstation 4 and PC
starting on the 19th over 6.4 million
players participated in the beta the
division was eventually released on the
8th of March 2016 two years after its
initially planned release the game broke
company records including the highest
number of sales on the first day the
division also broke the industry record
for the biggest first week launch for a
new game franchise generating an
estimated three hundred and thirty
million dollars globally unfortunately
this wasn't completely represented in
the reviews and customer response which
provided mixed emotions within days
there were comparison videos popping up
online showing the difference between
what was shown at e3 and the final
product with the graphics had obviously
been tapered back initial feedback also
talked about how the map looked
considerably less vibrant with long
stretches of endless walking where very
little happens and that the lack of
variety in activities made the game
tedious and a large number of ways the
game was also plagued with bugs and
connectivity issues where players were
either unable to keep a constant
connection to the service or couldn't
get on at all these issues plus a lack
of in-game content saw player numbers
drop rapidly after release in April of
2016 update 1.1 was released server
issues for the most part have become
more stable the developers had also
sought out to revive some of the in-game
by introducing the first incursion to
the game Falcon lost weekly and daily
missions were also added to provide
incentive for players to jump into the
game on a more regular basis and players
could now trade gear with each other
patch 1.1 the first gear sets into the
game giving players something new and
more powerful to hunt for but also
adding considerably more built diversity
into the game up until this point the
fastest and most efficient way of
obtaining the best gear was through
crafting using the materials game
through missions and deconstructing
unwanted gear and weapons but the
developers felt that this was taken away
from the RPG element of the game so 1.1
included quite a hefty increase in
crafting material cost in order to have
RNG player large apartment finding those
most sought after pieces these updates
were well received but unfortunately
they also introduced some new problems
into the game the game's most
sought-after gear was awarded to players
on completion of the incursion but
naturally with a game of this type
players quickly found ways to manipulate
and abuse mechanics in order to gain
advantage
the developers received criticism for
how they handled this would players
saying it took too long to fix and that
the abusers were not being punished with
the introduction of gear sets into the
game the games built diversity should
have become better than ever
unfortunately this was not the case in
fact it was quite the opposite the
sentries call set paired with an SMG
proved to be so unbalanced versus the
other gear available that there was no
other option but to equip the spells in
order to stay competitive
[Music]
[Music]
in May 2016 update 1.2 was announced
codenamed conflict it was better known
as time as they've cut the rope update
this was due to an update that we now
allow players to hijack other players
extractions further adding to the
high-risk high-reward nature of the dark
zone but also opening up on the rift
between PvE and PvP players roaming the
area a new incursion was released play
sky and four new gear sets 1.2 also
included a general loop drop increase
across the board making players feel
like their time was being more
adequately rewarded in order to combat
the stagnated build meter the sentries
called for peace bonus will now only
apply to semi-automatic weapons but with
this DP is heavy meter seeming put to
rest a new meter would rise the tank
meter and what can only be assumed as a
way to further combat the previous DPS
meter the armoured damage mitigation cap
was increased to 75% hugely increasing
the time to kill and PvP this coupled
with a high damage set like technicians
Authority running a capped VfB sticky
bomb and we have the tactician built
like the minute before it has had no
true counter
June 2016 the first expansion
underground and update 1.3 was released
this was a PvE based update with a major
feature underground supplied players
with a mission type that would never be
the same as the last time it was run
also included was a new incursion
Dragon's nest and five new gear sets and
the existing weapon pool was increased
with nine new weapon types being added
to the mix one of the notable gameplay
changes in this update was a
considerable buff to the base damage of
all shotguns up until this point they
were relatively unused for the most part
but what the developers didn't see
coming was that this new super whip in a
close range coupled with the newly
adjusted sentries call set would create
one of the most memorable meters that
the game would see
[Music]
in October 2016 the game in its current
state was in a bit of trouble with
gameplay stagnating the PvP scene only
really been dominated by one or two
build options and each new patch adding
more bugs and it seemed to be removing
the player base was starting to thin out
the developers thought this is a time
for a full game overhaul update 1.4 was
released and very little was left
untouched
this update had changes made to weapons
gear sets skills talents all with the
intention of breaking the current meters
and best in slots and resetting the
state of the game world tiers were
introduced to help new players with a
cleaner way to progress towards the
in-game a much debated topic npc time to
kill was reduced in order to make the
NPC's list bullet spongy on top of this
a number of improvements were made to
the AI and an increase to all loot drops
across the board had been put in place
of course the players still found a new
meter within this update but it wasn't
to the same unmatchable caliber of
previous meters November 2016 update 1.5
lands including a new survival mode this
new mode was separate to the main game
stripping players of gear and forcing
them to make their way to the middle of
the map to be extracted before infection
took them down named weapons had existed
since launch but 1.5 introduced a number
of named gear pieces these were unique
and offered abilities not seen on other
gear a new set was added and twelve new
weapon types for the weapon balancing
was included to try and reduce the
growing meter from the last update but
the Alpha bridge built was still raining
strong this patch was well received by
the community with most saying it was
well overdue and this was beginning to
show with increased coverage on
streaming platforms like twitch
you
[Music]
[Music]
with the third and final paid DLC and
expansion to the PvP aspect of the game
was introduced in February 2017 last
stand was in addition to PvP that could
previously only be experienced in the
dark zone this pitted players together
in even teams fighting towards a common
objective on top of this the dark zone
was expanded to allow farming players
more room to avoid those looking for PvP
and three of the existing missions had a
new difficulty added to the legendary
named Garen weapons were renamed to
exotic but probably the biggest thing
introduced by this update were the
changes made towards interrupting the
meter that have been around since patch
1.2 armor and the way it works was being
changed the Alpha bridge four-piece
bonus was updated so that it shares the
free talent from your weapons instead of
all three effectively squashing the
Alpha bridge shotgun meter changes to
the way that skill pal works was also
implemented so the built focus solely on
school power would now become a viable
option however this gave birth to the
1.6 one-shot Sakuma meter
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
six months pass after 1.6 update and
over this time players continue to move
on to other titles due to the lack of
in-game and limited number of
competitive build options available and
it was starting to show in the
matchmaking results of activities like
survival and last stand in August 2017
update 1.7 offered some relief The
Seeker mine meta was dealt a hefty nerf
which would render the PvP skilled power
of damage build completely crippled
never to be seen as a viable PvP option
again time limited events called global
events they completely mix-up the style
of play offered in PvP were added and
with these came new vanity face masks
that could be collected the introduction
of commendations and patches go players
that have invested hundreds and
thousands of hours into the game
something new to grind for and something
that would act as a badge of recognition
for time spent a new type of cash could
be obtained through the premium vendor
these encrypted caches could be
purchased using cyber keys that are
collected during normal gameplay and
commendation completion but could also
be purchased using real world currency
the encrypted caches contained a large
number of vanity items and emotes to
allow players to further customize their
experience so much like the
commendations players had something to
show for the time spent in game and
finally the exotic a ninja bike
messenger backpack had a complete rework
previously this exotic was considered
trashed here but the 1.7 update turned
us into the most sought-after gear piece
in the game the 1.7 patch and the ninja
bike bag opened up built diversity
options to Heights that never seen
before this new uncharted territory
offered theorycraft is a huge range of
options and brought gear back into the
game that otherwise was considered as
inefficient and worthless for the first
time that didn't seem to be a Mitter
that completely outclassed all other
belts but this wasn't long-lived 1.7
also introduced classified gear since
this new gear offered even greater power
to existing sets by allowing even
greater bonuses via the 5th in 6 piece
although the true effect of classified
gear on the games built diversity
wouldn't be noticed until much later on
although it was 1.7 that fixed a lot of
the game-breaking issues who wasn't
until 1.8 was released that the gaming
community started taking notice
1.8 expanded on the successes of 1.7 by
further introducing a large map
expansion to the Westside peers a new
dedicated PvP activity was added
skirmish and a PvE halt mode resistance
the underground released back in June
2016 received some much-needed attention
and more vanity items were added to the
premium vendor the rest of the
classified sets were introduced
alongside the new global events and new
exotic weapons were added to the loop
further balances were applied across all
areas player numbers were at levels
Ruggles only by the initial launch of
the game new players were joining the
community and streamers and content
creators were started to return updates
1.7 and 1.8 had added long overdue
changes to the game and this was exactly
what the community was after at this
point in time the division of resent an
all-time high but now that they had the
attention of the gaming community what
would be the next move I'm thrilled on
behalf of the the team at massif and the
teams that are working on the division
worldwide to exclusively announce to our
community first that we're working on
the sequel to the division the division
to March 2018 during the state of the
game stream it was announced that the
division 2 was being worked on the
developers went further to say that
there being a small team working on it
since about a week after the division 1
was released due to recent events in the
gaming community there was a lot of
discussion around whether the division
should be focusing on continuing to
expand or to release a sequel it wasn't
an easy decision but there are so many
stories and so many expiry
we explore within the world of the
division that we really felt that a
sequel was the best way to to
investigate these things incredible
opportunity for us to take all that
learning all that experience from what
the division is today and put that into
a newly no further details on the
division to are to be released until III
2018 the community developers win on to
answer questions about the future of the
division one by stating to further
updates will add new global events new
legendary missions and a monthly feature
called shields and which achievements
earned playing the division will grant
special awards in the division to
over the two-plus years that the
division has been active its had its ups
and downs the triple-a title started off
with a bang but numerous bugs and
imbalances caused a fall from grace that
took almost two years to recover from
but problems aside the division has
gained a loyal following that will
continue the franchise into a second
installment with ease the biggest
question is will they listen to this
loyal community or they follow the
industry trend of oversimplifying the
game to appeal to the masses
[Music]